We have a voicemail number, which you can
call anytime.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. Here is yet another caller who I
fear may be understating the importance of
voting if you're in a very blue or very red
state.
Take a listen.
Hey, David, I have a quick question.
I myself am from New York State, Young, the
subject of voting.
I'm wondering those who know that their county
or state or district.
Whatever is going to go blue right under,
you know, regardless of the individual votes,
what would you say to people like myself and
others that might not necessarily think that
it's worth going to the effort to vote by
mail or just to vote at all?
Yeah.
So I would tell you, you are very, very wrong.
This election in particular is a crucial election
in which we have to run up the score.
By that, I mean we need votes for Biden in
blue states that Biden will win easily.
And we need votes for Biden in red states
that Biden will very much lose because the
larger the margin, the more difficult it will
be for a court to give anything to Trump if
he tries to challenge the results in one state,
nationally.
Whatever.
It's never been more important to vote than
this year, regardless of what's happening
in your state.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about Corona virus and the Sturgis
motorcycle rally.
It's not just USPS, it's also FedEx deliveries
that are delayed.
I'll tell you why.
And my Tesla stock, my Tesla stock down 21
percent in one day.
What the hell happened?
Did I sell any in advance?
I will give you the full rundown on today's
bonus show.
Don't miss it.
Become a member.
Join Pacman dot com to get instant access
to the bonus show.